I though my name is Evan I am 16 years
old here's my question for you our
physical traits such as height
determined mostly by genes or by
nutrition exercise give me a percentage
number my mama and I are having an
argument over this i heavily believe
that it's more the genes that contribute
to this trait such as height Thank You
Evan it's a great question the right
answer is clearly both so some people
are genetically predisposed to be tall
as you point out but I can tell you
people in the West
and out like in our civilization here in
the United States Canada are getting
taller offspring are growing taller and
taller and that is almost certainly due
to improve nutrition and archaeologists
who love this stuff go digging up old
graves in big cities and they find that
people in the 1700s in the 18th century
word not as tall as their descendants
are today and this is almost certainly a
result of nutrition so it's it's both
furthermore something that just
fascinates me in Africa everybody all of
our ancestors are ultimately from Africa
and Africa you find indigenous people
people who've tribes who have lived
there for millennia that are both very
tall where food is abundant and there's
other tribes that are not especially
tall where food is harder to get and
it's just fascinating right there to
this day you can find where the
environment that the evolutionary
pressure to find nutrition to find food
has affected the success of offspring if
you're too tall and there's not enough
food around you can't feed yourself and
so you don't have kids if on the other
hand you live where food is abundant
fruits growing on trees as the saying
goes you can be taller and be just
ultimately a more a bigger animal in the
same forest in the same jungle and just
be more successful so the answer is both
you got eat
breakfast I'll leave with you I'll leave
you with that if you don't eat breakfast
you're just you're just not going to be
as successful in life